- WE'RE THE GUYS.
- MM-HMM.
- I GOT YOU A GIFT.
- YEAH.
- I HOPE YOU ENJOY IT.
IT IS THE BOOK TWILIGHT.
- OH.
- IT'S ABOUT--
IT'S BASICALLY YOU.
IT'S, LIKE, A STRONG, EMPOWERED
WOMAN WHO FALLS IN LOVE
WITH, UH, A DUDE
WITH A DOPE HAIRLINE.
- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
- YOU'RE WELCOME.
UH, IF YOU WANT
TO COME ON IN HERE...
W-WOULD YOU LIKE ANYTHING
FROM THE BREAK ROOM?
WE GOT WATER IN THERE.
WE GOT SOME OLD BANANAS.
WE GOT SOME
MULTI-GRAIN CHEERIOS.
- OH, NO, THANK YOU.
I'M ON KIND OF A TIGHT SCHEDULE.
SO WHAT'S THE STORY?
- WELL, THE STORY STARTS
WITH A BROKE-DOWN 'VO
AND HOPEFULLY WILL END WITH YOU
BEING OUR A-LIST CELEBRITY
AT THE 'VO FUND-RAISER PARTY
THIS WEEKEND.
- IT'S A FUND-RAISER?
- YEAH.
- SEE, I WAS TOLD
THAT THERE WERE UNSAFE
WORK CONDITIONS HERE.
- THERE IS.
- THERE ARE, YEAH.
THERE'S A TON, LIKE,
UM, THE BREAK ROOM?
YEAH, IT'S MORE LIKE THE
SLIP-AND-BREAK-YOUR-NECK ROOM.
YOU CAN REALLY BUST YOUR NUT
IN THERE.
- OKAY. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR WASTING MY TIME.
- WHAT?
all: NO, NO, NO, NO.
- NO, NO, NO, NO, NO,
NO, NO, NO, NO.
HEY.
AH, I'M SORRY.
I PROBABLY CAME OFF
AS A REAL FREAKIN' PERV.
[mumbling incoherently]
- [laughs]
- IT'S LIKE YOU...
- YEAH.
- M-MAKE ME ALL FLUSTERED.
WE WANT YOU TO COME
TO OUR 'VO FUND-RAISER
BECAUSE IT MEANS
THE WORLD TO US,
AND IF YOU'D JUST
SPEND SOME TIME WITH US,
YOU'D REALIZE
THAT WE'RE COOL, NORMAL DUDES.
WE MAKE FUNNY JOKES.
WE DO FUNNY PRANKS.
- OH, SO MANY FUNNY PRANKS.
- YEAH.
- LIKE, UH--
LIKE WORLD-STAR-WORTHY STUFF.
LIKE, UH, WE DO SMACK HAMS.
WE MESS WITH PEOPLE'S FOOD.
[laughter]
- WE DO EUROPEAN SHARKING,
WHICH--GOOGLE THAT.
- PHONE CALLS.
- YES.
- WE DO THOSE ALL DAY
TO, LIKE, OLD PEOPLE AND STUFF,
SO IT'S FUNNIER.
- WE MAKE 'EM BUY
THE STUPIDEST [bleep]...
ALMOST LIKE IT'S OUR JOBS.
- RIGHT.
- WAIT A MINUTE.
IT IS.
[laughter]
- IT IS. WE'RE TELEMARKETERS.
DOY!
- YES.
- WHAT WE DO IS WE'LL JUST
TARGET OLD PEOPLE, YOU KNOW?
WE'LL LOOK AT THE LIST,
AND THEN WE'LL BE LIKE,
"THAT'S AN OLD NAME.
THAT'S A LONELY NAME.
WE'RE GONNA CALL THAT NAME."
- EDITH?
I WILL [bleep] AN EDITH.
OVER!
I'M SORRY.
OH, GOSH. I JUST--I-I, LIKE,
STOPPED THE SENTENCE.
- OKAY. WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I-I HAVE AN HOUR TO KILL
BEFORE MY NEXT MEETING,
SO I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
SOME OF THOSE PRANK PHONE CALLS.
- COOL. AWESOME.
- COOL.
- OKAY. YES. YES, BUT FIRST,
YOU GOT TO SEE
SOME OF THE CLASSICS.
- OKAY.
- WILL YOU TOUCH POOP?
[rock music]
♪
[air horn blows]
[laughter]
- OH, [bleep].
- REGULAR DAY IN THE OFFICE.
- WHERE WE WORK.
all:
POOP DOLLAR!
[laughter]
- THAT IS MY POOP!
- [coughing]
♪
- IT WOULD BE, LIKE, AN HONOR
IF YOU'D, LIKE, SMOKE WITH US.
- AAH!
GOD, IT'S SO HOT!
MY [bleep] MOUTH,
MY [bleep] THROAT!
- WHO DOES THE BEST, UH, FACE,
LIKE, RIGHT BEFORE
YOU'RE ABOUT TO GET KILLED?
- GO. GO!
[high-pitched voice]
HEY, GRANDMA? IT'S ME, RICKY.
YEAH, I'M SELLING MAGAZINES
FOR SCHOOL AGAIN,
SO I NEED
A LITTLE BIT OF MONEY.
- [weakly] ETHEL, THIS IS
THE SPIRIT OF YOUR DEAD HUSBAND.
THEY WON'T RELEASE ME FROM HELL
UNLESS YOU BUY SOME STEAKS.
[groans]
- [deep voice]
YEAH, NOW, UH, REAL QUICK--
I'M GONNA NEED
THE EXPIRATION DATE
AND THE THREE-DIGIT CODE
ON THE BACK.
THAT IS VERY GOOD, DORIS.
YOU PASS YOUR ALZHEIMER'S TEST.
UH, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[normal voice]
AND I GOT HER.